hmm nice packaging and they even nailed
the new gadgets smell oh cool he plugged
this dongle into your iPhone to transfer
over your stuff text messages yes photos
yes
calendar yes I guess now we wait for
letters across yeah this is a fake plans
I think all right iPhone let's not make
this emotional look at this beautiful
beautiful headphone port take that
iPhone 7 wait who decided to put this
thing up here okay Google what's the
fastest subway to Brooklyn Bridge Park
from 47 to 50 STS Rockefeller Center
damn she's way better than Siri what's
your name again you can call me your
Google assistant what kind of name is
that
this boat is fast faster than any other
Android phone I've ever tested no lag
anywhere and these Google apps are way
faster and more fluid on this than on my
iPhone it's the Gmail and Google Docs
dream and third party Android apps seem
to have gotten a lot better I guess I
should text drew that I'm gonna be late
for dinner so many important things to
do I miss iMessage what's happening in
these stickers Google I really do love
to feel this iPhone though oh sorry
pixel even if it does have this thick
bezel and this shiny square thingy but
you know what I am getting the hang of
this fingerprint sensor being on the
back ok Google how old is too old to
ride a carousel ok never too old alright
let's put this highest rated smartphone
camera claim to the test
wow these shots look awesome if you
never had too many photos of creepy fake
horses especially since the pixel comes
with unlimited cloud storage for photos
and video the AMOLED screen is also much
brighter and crisper than the iPhone so
the photos look way better on here does
anyone have a barf bag it's
disappointing that there isn't a second
camera for zooming like the iPhone 7
plus though and this blur effects
software tool looks pretty fake I would
totally go swimming if this phone was
water-resistant like the Samsung Galaxy
s7 and the
seven and if I didn't think this water
would leave me smelling like a foot low
power mode time I definitely worry more
about battery life on here than on the
iPhone 7 the bigger pixel XL is
definitely the better choice for all day
juice mi at pani vino what's it to you
Google I really don't like how easy it
is to give Google more information than
you'd want and the settings to disable
it are hard to find
ok maybe the answers in here
ok pixel you are a fabulous phone the
best Android phone money can buy of
course the other one explodes when it
comes to hardware I wouldn't miss much
about the iPhone but leaving the Apple
ecosystem is hard especially when I
consider iMessage and the privacy
trade-offs but oh that camera
you